>> I'm Carolina you might have heard that
this is the tenth anniversary of JSConf EU!
[Cheering and applause].
But you might also have heard that, for now,
this is the last one.
But, this seems like a great opportunity for
us to give you a little bit of a look at how
it all got started.
>> So the history of JSConf EU began in Washington,
DC ten years ago in 2009.
This event is often described as a homecoming
for the JavaScript community, because that
might be hard for you to believe right now,
but back then, the JavaScript community kind
of didn't exist.
A lot of people were PHP programmers doing
Ruby and Python and doing a bit of JavaScript.
Nobody felt that JavaScript is my home.
JSConf EU 2009 brought that space together
and changed the landscaping space forever.
>> Holger, Jan and Malte met at that first
JSConf US and decided they needed to bring
that community to Europe.
In 2009, they chose a venue, and, with no
other prior experience planning a conference,
they got started.
Lucky for them, Marina worked there, and she
helped bring that conference to live, and
a few months later when they were planning
the next conference, they found that Marina
didn't work there any more, and they were
panicked and approached there, and since then,
she's been working with the conference every
single year.
A little-known secret: Marina is a huge part
of this conference.
Please applaud Marina!
[Applause].
She is the one who suggested the bubble track.
If you remember that?
Anyway, not this year.
So the original JSConf was Jan, Holger, and
Malte.
These were not the only people who have been
a part of this amazing organising team.
In 2012, Tiffany joins, and then in 2015,
Simone.
For a year, I was a part of the team before
moving to Australia and starting - actually,
just cultivating a local chapter of JSConf
and CSSConf Australia, and Feli joined as
the newest team member.
As someone who is organiser, I think it's
fair to shall I that JSConf EU had a little
impact on the tech community starting in the
first year when Ryan Dahl showed JS for the
first time, and it was one of the only tech
conferences with a standing ovation.
I missed it.
I was in the other track.
And then, last year, he demoed Deno, his new
JavaScript run time, and of course, Deno is
based on typescript which was also I understood
Democratic Unionist at JSConf EU.
Finally, the not-so-super-well-received React
was at JSConf US but then represented at Pete
Hunt.
JSConf was never supposed to be a big conference.
Yet here we are with 1,600 people right now.
The strategy for JSConf from the early days
was to have a lot of small conferences around
the globe to provide local communities to
be distributed, and also to lower the environmental
impact of flying people around.
While organising conferences now we have 14
JSConfs, some active and retired - EU, Australia,
China, Colombia would be Brazil, Belgium,
China, and I hope I didn't forget anyone.
[Cheering].
>> There are a lot of them.
And that's not mentioning any satellite events
and JSConf family events.
It's
a huge family now.
JSConf EU didn't just spawn more JSConfs around
the world.
In 2011, Reject US which was originally conceived
as a platform for the great talks that got
rejected, and it was a lower prised event
aimed at locals which got its own cult following.
CSSConf came to
the US as well in 2013.
They may have heard that just like JSConf,
CSSConf is also taking a break, but that means
it's completely over.
Their last conference was yesterday.
Round of applause if you went yesterday!
[Applause].
One of the things that makes JSConf and CSSConf
very special and welcoming place is inclusion.
And JSConf is one of the first events in tech
which implemented and enforced a code of conduct,
provided childcare, built an anonymous Call
for Speakers process that minimises bias,
and they really put an effort into maximising
the participation from under-represented groups
in every single aspect of the event.
So diversity and inclusion is one of the core
values at JSConf, because anyone, no matter
their race, gender, age, socio-economic status,
ability, should be able to safely participate
in the tech community, be treated equally,
and be welcome.
>> Applause to that!
[Applause].
>> Wow!
I didn't do that.
I promise!
I just pressed a button.
We can keep going.
We can just go.
>> Let's keep going!
Imagine tweets, imagine excited tweets from
people - picture tweets!
Okay, key can go.
We can go through this again.
Yes, we've talked about this.
>> Recap of the recap!
>> Been there, done that!
Yep, yep!
Previously on JSConf EU!
>> It's the gifs that are breaking it, I swear.
>> Success.
Getting back on track.
So one of the most exciting and great manifestations
of that inclusion strategy is the scholarship
programme that's been run by JSConf EU JSConf
and CSSConf as well.
This programme allows people who couldn't
attend these events otherwise to attend for
free.
This programme has started friendships, careers,
and built amazing connections.
One of the examples of that is Sun Li is the
participant and now the organiser of the first
JSConf Korea!
[Applause].
So it's just incredible to see the effect
of this programme that it
can have
on somebody's life.
>> So
we want to thank right now everyone who supported
this programme, both this year and in previous
years.
People, like yourselves, contributing to this
programme.
All the sponsors this year, every single one
of them contributed to the programme.
We want especially to thank Google and Glitch
who directly contributed to the programme,
and this programme has grown so significantly
that, this year, there are 150 scholarships
given out for CSSconf and JSConf.
Congratulations on that!
[Applause].
>> It's really important to address those
of you who are here because of this programme.
I want to welcome you to JSConf, welcome you
to this community.
We are so, so happy and privileged to have
you, so welcome, and I hope you have a wonderful
time here.
[Cheering and applause].
>> If anything, JSConf has made a lot of people
happy, and we hope we see a lot more smiling
faces today.
I was at that first JSConf EU, and I can tell
you that was the first time I felt I was part
of my professional community.
I'm going to lose if - shit!
Maybe this conf was that for you too.
We're part of a diverse community, we are
going to have a great time, and enjoy the
rest of the show!
[Cheering and applause].
[Music].
* Everybody sing - oh, baby!
* Oh, never, ever ... some day.
* Some day.
* Some day, woah ...
* Never forget where you're coming from.
* Never pretend that it's all real.
* Some day, it will be someone else's dream
...
* Never forget where you're coming from.
* Never pretend that it's all real.
* Some day, it will be someone else's dream,
woaaah.
* And we reach so high.
* And we learn each day and night.
* And it feels so young.
* And we... more.
[Cheering and applause].